everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
looking at the portuguese gambit which
derives from the scandinavian offense
which is e for d5 and it comes from the
accepted line so the pend takes here on
d5 and then Knight to f6 now i can try
to hold on to this material there's
reasons that many players don't want to
it can really mess up their entire
structure if they do so normally you'll
see white just play a normal development
move that could be Knight to f3
it could be d4 could be Knight to c3 not
really trying to hold on to the material
just trying to get more pieces involved
into the game but d4 is one of the more
common responses that white has says
yeah I don't care if you take care on d5
which is the most common response from
black and then Knight to f3 get their
light square Bishop involvements of the
game castle on the Kings side things are
pretty normal from whites but black does
not have to take care on d5 and that's
what we're gonna be going over the
Portuguese game it says I don't want to
take that material back I'm okay being
down the material I just want active
pieces bringing the bishop here to g4
attacking the Queen here on d1 is the
plan this plays very similar to the
Icelandic game it have another video on
that if you want to take a look but they
just says yeah I'm just giving up
material here I just want a lot of
active pieces attacking my opponent and
I don't mind if they start to extend and
only move their pawns so if they're
playing things like f3 and I can just
start to develop more and more of my
pieces and they're not moving any of
their pieces on this backline that's
gonna be a good thing for me so there's
a few variations that you could see from
white after you play Bishop to g4 we're
gonna go over all of them but f3 is
gonna be one of them you could see
Knight to f3 both of those blocking the
Queen right here or another one would
just be the knight coming to e2 those
all three are gonna block the bishop
they could also play Bishop to b5 check
says yeah I'm gonna ignore this right
now I'm gonna attack your King you have
to do something about it
so those are the lines we're gonna be
going over the first one which i think
is going to be the most common that
you'll see is going to be f3
now from here the Bishop's gonna come
back to f5 you're not playing the
Portuguese gambit to bring your Bishop
back to d7 and retreat you want to stick
in there and have a very aggressive
attack so Bishop to f5 and they have
some options from here they could look
at and say okay I'm up material here so
I want to hold on to some this d5 pawn
maybe now since they're pawns in our
attack on c2 they bring it up to c4
really trying to control the pawn
structure here on the Queen side the
board this is going to be completely
okay but you have to recognize that the
point of this opening is to get more
material involved you may have to give
up even more to accomplish that meaning
the best move for black here is to play
e6 saying yeah you can take more
material now they don't have to take
material if they eventually say okay I
don't want to extend even more they
could play Knight to c3 here and then
you can exchange so maybe pawn takes if
they take you take with your Knights if
they want to take that's completely fine
if they castle on the Kings side they
don't have as strong as King side safety
as you would once you get your darks for
a bishop involvement of the game castle
on the King side you can even cast on
the Queen side depending on what the
board state looks like if they don't
take that pawn maybe you take here on d5
and then they want to push on the King
side the board your bishop can easily
come back here and you can see they've
completely extended on the King side of
the board their Queen side everything is
just wide open you're gonna be attacking
very very freely or you could be playing
moves like Bishop to before pinning down
there Knight casts on the King side you
can have a very good board state now if
we come back a little bit more and say
what if they don't play the Knight to c3
what if they continue to gobble up
material that's fine if they take here
recognize you're not gonna be taking
this material back that's not the name
of the game you want to get more
material involved into the game so they
take materials say great I'm gonna plate
Knight to c6 now if they take here on f7
then your King is going to recapture
here on f7 you have to you're in check
so now at this point you do need to do
something but if you look at this setup
right here
White's definitely up in material
no question about it up to pons and King
doesn't have a ton of safety I mean he
can't castle on either side of the board
but if you look at it White has not
moved any of his pieces here black on
the other hand has two knights in the
center of the board attacking a lot of
material the knight and the queen are
attacking this pawn here on d4 the
bishop can easily get involved into the
game how does white really continue here
with knowing that they're up material
but they can't really attack anything
and they were gonna be playing defense
and in some regards so maybe they play
d5 say yeah I need to attack some
material here this sets up a pawn chain
here will black continue to get more
material involved into the game can play
Bishop to c5 what's nice about this is
while this pawns attacking the knight
the pond can't actually take this night
here on c6 I mean it can but then mike
has the nice move of Bishop to f2 now if
the King takes here we can obviously see
the Queen's gonna take here on d1 that's
gonna be bad for whites but even if he
doesn't if he comes up to e2 well then
the works gonna swing over to e8 check
and then there's nothing else they can
do here they if they bring their Bishop
they're just gonna lose that the the
rook can come down here they could take
with their Bishop they have some couple
options here but the King pretty much
has to take care enough to and then the
Queen is going to fall so if we come
back and say yes the bishop comes up
here to c5 now both the bishops are
involved into the game
how does white really continue from here
there's not a lot of good options for
white if they try something like Bishop
to e2 just getting something in front of
their King so that maybe later on they
can castle on the King side you're gonna
be playing Knight to d4 yes your pawn
what your knight was being attacked so
you can just come here great little
outpost here then they can't do much
about their Knight can't come to f3 or
e2 so it's kind of stuck here no good
options for white now they don't have to
play d5 but depending on where they go
you're going to be able to attack
because you have so much material
they're going to be moving one piece at
a time and then you can just tee all
on whatever piece that they move so
that's what's gonna happen if they
decide to come a little further attack
here on f7 and you recapture with your
king now they don't have to play c4 if
instead of playing c4 they play
something like g4 this is we talked
about before they're extending quite a
bit on the Kings side of the board I
would just come back to g6 you still
want to keep this Bishop involved into
the game you don't want to retreat to
something like d7 now if they play c4
it's gonna be very similar before you're
gonna play e6 same as we just talked
about one thing is if you see h4 because
maybe they just completely say okay
gotta go all-in on the kingside the
boards you do need to stop that so be
looking for h5 here you're probably not
gonna be casting on the King side of the
board yourself but you do need to stop
that now if they decide to attack maybe
Bishop to b5 check in this case just go
ahead and play c6 if they want exchange
I would first recapture with your knight
here if they want to take here that's
gonna be completely fine you can see
black has a pretty good setup here it's
gonna be very easy to play e6 or e5
bring your dark square Bishop involved
into the game castle on the King side if
you look from whites perspective
he has three moves at least before he
can cast on the Queen side black on the
other hand he can easily move his rook
here to b8 he has his bishop here on g6
looking to attack here on the Queen side
of the board so why it's gonna be
struggling to find a lot of defense
while Black has a good set up already if
we come back to the beginning here after
Bishop g4 you could see Knight f3 this
is a pretty common move it does stop the
threat here with the Bishop attacking
the Queen in this case go ahead and take
with your queen on at d5 you want to get
more material involved into the game
that is our strategy in the Portuguese
gambit so you could take with your
knight but I recommend with your Queen
but this does generally lead to Knight
to c3 it's getting more material
involved for white attacking the Queen
and then just bring your Queen over here
to f5 you don't just want to retreat
bring
back here to d8 that's no fun that's not
the reason why you're playing this
opening in the first place but not too
many variations to go over just because
you will see Knight to c3 like 90 plus
percent of the time now if we don't see
Knight to c3 another pretty common
opening is Bishop to b5 this is check
it's forcing black to do something here
and I recommend just c6 we've seen this
in the other variations
it puts white to the test here both
their Queens on our attack in the Bishop
Center attacks so what do they do if we
start to attack right here with the pawn
then I would recommend taking with of
the night if you take their queen up
here then they can just play their pawn
down here they're gonna take our queen
and check our King so don't recommend
that just go ahead and take with your
knight if they take with their Bishop we
recapture with their pawn that's
completely fine now if they play Knight
to f3 Black has a nice little move of
pawn to c5 and it kinda looks right off
the bat of like hey why would you do
this you're just giving up some material
here because after the pawn then the
Queen can take here on a t1 after the
King takes then we have e 5 now why is
this important because this Knights
being pinned down to the King this
Knight cannot move here this also opens
up the door for the bishop here on f8 to
take back this material so this nights
gonna be under attack here so one of two
things is gonna happen one is this King
is gonna move there's gonna be a Knights
maybe coming here to d2 trying to hold
onto this material pawn comes up here to
e4 this nights going to fall if not
though then the bishop can just take
here on c5 and black has a pretty good
game now all in all if they play Bishop
to b5 that's one of the better options
that they have so I wouldn't say that's
necessarily a great thing for black a
lot of the attacking lines that you want
to be playing you're not gonna get to if
they play Bishop to b5 you're gonna be
giving up a lot of material especially
with the exchange not gonna be as
exciting but you have to be aware that
they could definitely play Bishop to b5
last variation then I'll go over is one
this network
but you could see Knight to e2 in this
case same as if they brought their
knight to f3 I'll just go ahead and
bring my queen take it here on d5 I'm
probably going to be playing c3 but the
key difference here is in this example I
would not play Queen to f5 and this is
one of the reasons that you may see the
Knight to e2 is they're really baiting
black to come here to f5 because it
seems pretty logical but the key
difference is because the Knights not on
f3 then the pend can come to f3 and then
once the Bishop comes back here to h5
there's no other royal square here then
the knight can come to g3 and this is
attacking both the bishop and the Queen
here and this is just not a good spot
for black so because of that I would
just recommend your Queen coming over
here to a5 this is pinning down at the
knight to the King here still keeps it
very aggressive not coming back here to
d8 as some players may do there your
Bishop still pinning down at their
knight here
now the knight coming to e2 does open up
the door for f3 to come later on but
that's gonna be completely up fine you
can always just bring your Bishop back
to f5 as we've talked about so that is
the Portuguese game it definitely
recommend trying it out especially if
you play a lot of Scandinavian offense
which if you don't always recommend
trying it you're gonna see e5 or e for
from white so many times and I just
don't know how to respond when you play
d5 so play d5 they usually gonna capture
Knight to f6 you have just so many
options to play this let me know what
you guys think also if there's other
openings you want me to cover feel free
to let me know best way to reach me is
email the chess website at gmail.com
always looking for videos that you guys
want to watch but thank you guys for
watching the video
and I'll see you guys in the next one